hi Roger how are you of course I'm on
time I'm a Nixon guy you are extremely
proud annual yeah like they say if
you're if you're not if you're not not
early you're late is that what it is not
your leaves given the two options I
don't know I'm not going with
expressions from my point of view I can
be criticized for a lot of things but
punctuality and sartorial style no I
believe the expression is if you're on
time you're late
okay how have you never ah
you're amazing because you've survived
in Washington since the Nixon era how
have you managed to navigate all of the
people that have wanted to knock you out
of there or all the things that pop up
in a 40 year or 45 year career there
well politics ain't beanbag and I have
to admit the role of the press has
changed very dramatically in almost 40
years that I've been in American
politics newspaper stories television
stories used to have to be based in fact
evidence proof corroboration to
witnesses saying something and providing
some documentation today we got a new
standard the charge is the news in other
words I can go say you guys went and
took a dump in the woods I don't have to
prove it I can put it on page one just
because somebody said it that's hearsay
by and large so it's changed very
dramatically I intend to be around for
another 20 or 30 years but the fake news
thing you know it's a Kafka esque it's
almost like Alice in Wonderland you read
about things that never happen you read
charges by people who are nameless
faceless unidentified sources offering
no proof or corroboration just making
wild accusations against you that's kind
of a new thing now it's also the rush to
get it out and the 24-hour news cycle
things just kind of last longer and now
they have 24 hours of news to fill
instead of just an hour so hey so-and-so
said this
someone is reporting on each other's
reporting right who's reporting on the
story there is more of that than you can
believe so for example the Washington
Post as it turns out
me and says we have two sources both of
whom said they were interviewed by the
special counsel's office Mueller's team
one of them says that you flew to London
- have you told him you fool London to
have dinner with Julian Assange the
other one says you told them you that
you flew to London have dinner with
Julian Assange and you sent him an email
telling him you knew about the actual
contents of the upcoming WikiLeaks
disclosures so I said well the first one
is sam nunn bird Sam do another rail and
the other one is unknown to me but there
is no such email to my knowledge because
I can't say something that I didn't know
by the time they write their story the
two sources have now become two guys who
said the email that they allude to has
completely disappeared so now we
attribute to him the statement o stone
told me he knew that the WikiLeaks
disclosures pertained to John Podesta
and the Hillary Clinton campaign well no
I didn't not only did I not say that
that's not the question the Washington
Post reporter asked me so what happened
is that is they write their story
now Salon slate the worst of the worst
The Daily Beast they all reiterate that
story essentially recycled with a slight
twist change targeting Roger stone or or
change subject of the investigation to
target an investigation which is a an
egregious change those are two legal
things but we get to recycle this the
same story comes out 40 times you're
absolutely right they report on each
other's reporting it's in sensuous and
it's funny last time you were on the
show with us we were talking to you
about the conversation you had with Sam
number where you said you were having
dinner with Julian Assange and you made
pretty clear that that was obviously a
joke yep as there were no travel records
at all that you had ever been to the
country that he's in in England you had
never been to the embassy you did like
people would know this so you were
clearly joking however new evidence has
come forward that was being reported
yesterday I said on
so I know where it said that there is
now an email that's been leaked in the
in the in the nunberg hearing or
whatever all the evidence that he handed
over included an email the you sent to
him and in the email or perhaps an email
that he sent him that he said he turned
over who knows who knows but in the
email I'm milking a joke oh by the way
his response now I have released he said
great can I get his email address I want
to pass it on to Charlie Gasperi know at
Fox knows he's still guys oh yeah he
bought he clearly what a joke by the way
Gasper you know is a great journalist
and a good guy the point here of course
is there are two points one I watch that
CNN broadcast yeah do you think they
could get any pictures of me that are
any worse I'm never going to be i
remember be as good-looking as Anderson
Cooper but these guys go out of their
way to make me look like Methuselah
that's not a great shot no they picked
the very worst pictures they can find
and hey I've been in your studio I'm not
a bad-looking guy well comment on that
all the time very handsome man both you
guys came on to me so I did came on you
the point here is that the that the the
CNN page taken its entirety says two
things one unearthed recently discovered
interviews with Roger stone show that he
said that the WikiLeaks disclosures
regarding Hillary would be devastating
well those aren't unearthed or or just
discovered they've been on YouTube for
eight months available to anything
there's also can be found at the info
wars.com site where you know I do a
daily commentary for one hour every
single day so I know they've they've
been right there in plain sight just
that they hadn't listened to them where
did you get the intramurally they
recycle the whole dinner saying where
did you get the information I got to ask
when you said like oh yeah there is
WikiLeaks stuff coming out and this is
why I got an email from from an analyst
named Charles or tell who told me that
he had just spoken to James Rosen of Fox
News and that Fox told him
that the WikiLeaks material was
devastating I see I see you work your
sources in this business I've got to do
an hour of commentary every day right
but I didn't hear that from Julian
Assange or anyone in WikiLeaks in fact
since we're here we might as well get
this out of the way I never spoke to
communicated or email with Julian
Assange I never received anything from
WikiLeaks never in your life I did leave
her in your life no absolutely not
that that's the irony of this entire
thing what did you guys have for lunch
say again what did you guys have for
lunch yeah we know we never died all the
reason I really liked the woman from The
Wall Street Journal
who wrote kind of a precursor story to
see and her big her big breaking news
was stone told nunberg that he dined
with Assange this despite the fact that
my passport still shows I never left the
country
there's no airline record that shows I
left the country customs records would
prove I didn't arrive in in London the
security cameras at the Ecuadorian
Embassy would show that I didn't arrive
and he's not going anywhere
Asajj but additionally I provided for
them hotel receipts credit card receipts
and airline receipts show I was in
California on the exact days that they
say I was in London did you fly to
Florida to and you have a photo of like
a JetBlue flight to Miami from London I
was in New York I flew from New York to
LA I did what I had to do out there I
had a meeting with a Republican donor
named John Middleton I went to Dan
Tana's on Hollywood Boulevard kind of an
old Hollywood favorite best chicken
parmesan on the face of the planet and
then I returned to Miami as you know I
live in an undisclosed location in South
Florida I provided all of that
documentation yet The Wall Street
Journal continued to speculate that I
met with Asajj here's where they've got
me though and I'm completely busted when
I was in West Hollywood I did stay in
the London hotel that's like London and
that's like being in line for The Wall
Street Journal perhaps it is so
that Journal goes on with Anderson
Cooper this is her 50 minutes that's why
they write these flawed stories and she
says well one federal prosecutor told me
that dined could have been defined as
stone and Assange on FaceTime or Skype
and both eating at the same time could
be wheeze
give me a break guys who eats on
FaceTime were you going that's like an
anointing because while I was eating
dinner he would have been eating
breakfast the time change yeah he's
having he's having a goddamn London
broil at 9 o'clock in the morning and
that's just a reduced them trying to
still make it work when the etwood need
physical evidence proves that you aren't
there who thinks that you who are very
distinctive look you're gonna sneak into
the Ecuadorian Embassy how is that gonna
happen maybe add a moustache on that
might have a look you you can't leave
the country undetected look there are
others who think maybe I was taken by
private boat to France and I swam the
English Channel ridiculous by the moment
but it's part and parcel of the hysteria
that's built up around the get Donald
Trump thing look they need to get over
it the elections over whether you like
Trump or not he won yeah what do you
like her or not the the GDP economic
growth in country hit 3% it never it
never averaged more than 1.5 under
piraka Bhama
we got a boom going on here maybe that's
why the president's presidential it you
know his performance approval is moving
up and one pollster has it at 51% no you
know I don't watch CNN for the same
reason that I don't eat out of the
toilet wow you don't like fun things you
don't like the taste of [ __ ] unless it's
a texture thing yeah you know watching
alright so that's why you don't watch
CNN cuz you know I'd eat out of the
toilet exactly now what do you think of
Sinclair broadcasting because you know
we can talk about CNN's bias but it's
tough to say that Sinclair I wouldn't
say you could argue who has the bigger
bias but it's tough to say that there
isn't a clear bias from Sinclair
broadcasting when we see a montage like
we saw earlier this week
well alternatively therefore what
all the media outlets in the country
leaned to the left
I mean I guess I would argue that
Sinclair and to a certain extent Fox are
providing some balance people know when
they turn on the set or they go to the
internet what they want to watch what
they choose to watch and at least they
have choices but don't you think well I
much prefer Fox they reflect my
worldview and I think their reputation
for authenticity and accuracy is better
than the folks over at CNN I kind of
like Sinclair and I cover you know they
don't have a outlet in the market where
I live so I don't see it regularly but
particularly in the area of
documentaries I think they do a terrific
job but don't you think that people know
that about Fox they know about CNN they
like we know at this point where the
cable news networks are coming from so
you can watch what you want but don't
you think that most of the people that
are watching Sinclair number one until
this week didn't even know they were
watching Sinclair they just knew they
were watching their local show and
didn't weren't aware that there was this
sort of you know spin in a certain
direction being put on it has to be some
a counterbalance to CBS ABC and NBC I
mean they're they're all over there on
the Left CBS among the worst they like
the like the black birds jumping off the
telephone line after one has gone there
among the first to buy whatever The
Washington Post in the and Daily Beast
and these other fake news outlets dish
up for the American people that may or
may not be true how do you feel to now
Roger about dan Rather who's puttin a
nose to Deline the bit left says that he
said you might have finally met your
match and Muller that you're a smart guy
and you're a very smart guy and then he
says oh what a tangled web we weave when
we practice to deceive and he was saying
that you've never met a Decipherer of
deception of Muller's category and
sooner or later it may be later we will
know you saying mullah is a great
[ __ ] that's basically what dan
Rather was saying but he wanted to throw
in some Shakespeare right yeah I would
say to Dan Rather is a very bitter and
has a grudge against me because he
believes that that I was the one who
provided the Texas Air National Guard
documents that he never bothered to
authenticate and which essentially
destroyed his career who were you any
blames were you that one did you do that
actually no I had nothing to do with it
but the more I say I had nothing to do
with it the more everybody believes
therefore I must have so that I don't
know how to solve but he he is
interviewed with the young guys who made
the incredibly good Netflix documentary
get me Roger stone as he told them that
he believed I had taken him down so I
think he's got a little bias he may may
yes I know I'm glad that you don't have
any bias when critiquing the amazing
Netflix documentary get let's just get
right to it yes it's probably the
greatest single ever made in the history
of the world right other than that you
know I'm in politics my email is a
cornucopia of smoke and mirrors this is
about the creation of perceptions it's
about head fakes it's about abandoned
initiatives it's about strategic
triumphs there's all kinds of stuff in
there
there's no treason in there there's no
violation of the law which is why this
whole leaking of emails and then forcing
you to respond to them when they're
partial or in the case of the Atlantic
there they've been edited by the by the
the media outlet is a ridiculous game so
therefore you have to go to the bottom
line you have to get to the end of the
road which is as I've said to you guys
previously I had no advance notice of
the content source or or subject of the
WikiLeaks disclosures regarding Hillary
Clinton I never received anything from
WikiLeaks or Assange or anyone else that
could be described as allegedly hacked
emails and I never passed anything on to
Donald Trump nor did we ever discuss it
that's the bottom line
tell me the truth Mueller may mr.
Mueller have to go may have to go many
hours and many miles before he figures
that out but at the end of the day proof
evidence reality that is what matters in
this process and I don't have any
vulnerability in
those areas what is julian assange smell
like never smelled the bass all right
you know he probably smells a not very
good considering that the guy is cramped
in this tiny little yeah you know Warren
I mean you had this idea that the
Ecuadorian Embassy must be grand when I
was in England this year to speak to the
Oxford Union and the Cambridge Union and
the Durham Union which I all did in one
week which is pretty hard work you can
see those speeches on YouTube by the way
uh I went by there just to see what it
looks like because it's right around the
corner from Harrods
you know department store which is
pretty extraordinary in itself and I
dropped off a card to the guard really
just to protest the fact that I think
this guy's being unfairly imprisoned I
mean he's a virtual prison in this tiny
cramped little space it's no exercise no
fresh air you know he the only thing he
is getting his visits from his Baywatch
friend that part you know I kind of
admire what is your card say oh he said
uh thank you very much no no what is
your card say oh it's just a business
card oh just okay you ever talk to Pam
Anderson did not ring so you talk to Pam
Anderson a lot I sure would like to uh
you know I liked her back in the day and
I like her now so maybe that's what
Julian smells like who knows CJ was her
character's name on Baywatch I believe
CJ is now Roger you're also getting sued
for a hundred million for defamation
which again when you're getting sued the
number again it can be an arbitrary
number by a Chinese billionaire he's
kind of a mysterious guy well he just
you criticized him a hundred million
dollars get online pal first of all that
guy is but has a was it was a Chinese
intelligence agent I think they flipped
him and became an American intelligence
agent he's not a dissident he's not a
freedom fighter he is fighting
extradition to his native country
because of massive cyber financial
crimes that he's accused of uh this is
Steve bannon's handiwork one of those
amateurs in politics
[Laughter]
and you know I don't think his lawsuit
goes anywhere but my lawyers can't wait
to get this guy on the stand
oh you would you did from justice he's
in the country illegally he's camped out
at his apartment at sherry-netherland
they're in New York this is this is a I
think designed for the purposes of a
headline if he thinks I've got a hundred
million dollars he's really dumb did you
think that Steve Bannon was a joke and
needed a bath while the campaign was
going on and when you first met her
mirror and everything or was it more
like towards the end of his run with
Trump did you realize that he kind of
stunk as a person literally and wanted
to you know I look when I initially met
the guy I kind of liked him I was on his
radio show on Sirius number of times he
talked a good game he is of course
apolitical immature he's never been in a
campaign before he doesn't know how to
read a sophisticated poll he knows a
little about media I don't think he
knows much about the modern Republican
Party but I can tell you this he really
doesn't understand Donald Trump who I
have known for 40 years going out and
taking credit for things that Trump did
is a sure way to get your head lopped
off which is why Steve did get his head
lopped off I always kind of wondered why
the guy was a slob I mean why he didn't
shave while he didn't seem to be
familiar with soap and hot water he was
where he would wear three suits you know
three shirts on top of each other or
Lance that odor I'm told alcoholics are
often cold oh Jesus and the guy Emmy
just doesn't look healthy when he got
inside the White House and he didn't
help anybody else who was a veteran of
the Trump campaign get a job or get an
appointment I'm not talking about me
because I could never be confirmed by
the US Senate but many good people men
and women who worked very hard to
electrum and who were fully qualified to
serve the country Steve wouldn't help
anybody then when he got out numbered
internally and surrounded by enemies he
complained that he was alone no that was
his fault
so what Steve doesn't understand
is that people our policy in government
and if you want to affect policy you
have to promote good people he didn't
promote anybody but himself and he
promoted himself in two books the first
one was devil's bargain the second one
was this firing fury and he made the
classic mistake of essentially declaring
to the world that he made Donald Trump
you know that he's much smarter than
Donald Trump I think it's those things
are wrong how they get so close to Trump
how'd he get such a position of power
when he was doing these things wrong but
what was it was he just a good talker
did he happen to catch Trump's here on
something how did he get so close are
just financiers of Trump camp Trump's
campaign was the Mercer family from Long
Island and they were affiliated with
steve-o Donald Trump is a genius when it
comes to finding OPM other people's
money hmm
and he Nomi financing his campaign not
out of his own pocket for a billionaire
it's amazing how little of his own money
he end up spending I think he spent ten
million in the general part me in the
nomination phase and I think close to
six or seven in the general election
phase which is a pittance when you
consider that Mike Bloomberg for example
spend 175 million to get elected mayor
the first time so the Mercer's were his
patrons and I think the strings on their
money was you have to hire this poorly
dressed guy with no political experience
oh all joking aside how often do you
think that he showered you'll be talking
about like once a day and maybe you're
just exaggerating it or are we talking
about a guy who maybe showers once a
week or less yeah I invite you to go to
Google Images right now and look up
Steve Barron okay what's with the
abrasions and stuff on his skin fatigue
Oh what is that
there's just something you know
fundamentally unclean about the guy he
doesn't look like he is washed his hair
in a month fundamentally unclean you
never want to be described on the radio
is fundamentally unclean that's the
story that people should be going with
Roger stone says Steve Bannon quote
fundamentally clean that's what should
be on CNN
Lu look at this guy yeah I got a little
shorts on he likes to relax he does like
to relax he likes to be comfortable
doesn't spend a lot of time in the gym
so Roger let's have a book coming out
now it's gonna be coming out maybe
eighth which is almost about a month
from now it's gonna be called stones
rules how to win at politics business
and style so maybe you'll come in and
promote that and Rogers website is stone
cold truth know you're calm yeah just
think you're stone cold stone cold truth
calm the instant this book is available
gentlemen I'd be happy to come in studio
and give you both an autographed copy
and talk about it it's really just kind
of the things I learned in 40 years in
politics about life a lot of it's about
politics how to Punk the media how to
enrage the Liberals but you'll also
learn how to make my mother's marinara
sauce and we do have by the way the
proper amount of linen to show on the
cuff of a well tailored suit mark
there's a lot of useful information on
here in here for men and women who want
to succeed in life maybe I'll wear a
suit next time Roger comes in and
impress him maybe that's what we'll do
to honor Roger when he comes in we will
wear suits I will make the staff wear
suits as well absolutely yes suits when
you come let's do it we can all look
good on camera we'll remember this none
of us who wear suits huh
we just have [ __ ] love wear all right
Roger listen thank you for clearing that
up and for for coming on I always enjoy
talking to you yes well I appreciate
being with you guys my legal expenses
have now hit seven hundred and ninety
eight thousand dollars I'll Congrats so
all your avid Roger stone fans out there
in radioland can go to stone Defense
Fund comm stone Defense Fund dot-com
mrs. stone will really appreciate it